bonjour toute la presse européenne
souligne ce matin l'horreur de ce qui
s'est produit à bologne le véritable
massacre de 76 personnes l'explosion
était bien d'origine criminelle et toute
l'italie est en état de choc ce matin à
l'explosion a pris les dimensions d'une
affaire d'état nous rejoindrons notre
correspondant à rome club revelli
les jeux olympiques c'est fini mais le
mouvement olympique survivra-t-il aux
événements de ces dernières semaines
l as khroub et revient de moscou il nous
dira tout à l'heure ce qu'il en pense ce
sont les deux principaux titres d'un
journal ou nous évoquerons dans un
instant l'ensemble de l'actualité en
compagnie de daniel duigou
nous parlerons cinéma également tout à
l'heure mais tout de suite donc
commençons par le drame que vient de
vivre l'italie cette explosion en gare
de bologne
le bilan est donc terrible 76 morts et
plus de 200 blessés il s'agit bien d'un
acte criminel d'abord revendiquée par un
mouvement d'extrême droite les noyaux
armées révolutionnaires mais ce
mouvement a démenti quelques heures plus
tard en tout cas l'émotion est immense
en italie où l'on est pourtant presque
habitué au terrorisme pourrait-on dire
ce matin une grève générale de quatre
heures a été observée dans toute la
région de bologne
même dans toute l'italie et des
manifestations sont prévues à rome à
milan et à turin
manifestation à l'appel des syndicats
mais aussi à l'appel de mouvements
d'extrême gauche italien pendant toute
la journée d'hier des gerbes de fleurs
ont été déposées près de ce qui reste de
la gare de bologne pas grand chose
on attend une déclaration du premier
ministre italien sur cette affaire sur
place notre correspondant permanent club
revenus
averti enquête a pris du retard
maintenant avec la complicité de 84 à
milan rien à dire d'atteindre son point
culminant millions d'italiens en
vacances oui cette population italienne
est quand même un peu traumatisé par ce
qui s'est passé à bologne
ainsi hier soir en gare de naples il y
avait de la fumée sous un train à la
suite de l'échauffement des freins il ya
eu un mouvement de panique dans la
foulée trois personnes ont été blessées
l'autre événement du week-end c'était
vous savez la fin des choses alain picq
de moscou comme prévu l'urss a raflé
beaucoup de médailles 195 la france pour
sa part en ramène 14 seulement malgré le
boycottage américain vous avez vu toutes
les images des exploits des records et
des tricheries
vous connaissez tous les bilans de ce
que certains ont appelé les jeux de la
honte
georges marchais lui affirme de son côté
que moscou restera une date importante
dans l'histoire du mouvement
olympiques alors justement s'interroge
maintenant aujourd'hui sur l'avenir de
cette olympisme l as khroub et vous avez
suivi toutes les épreuves de moscou
alors à votre avis est-ce que les jeux
olympiques de los angeles auront lieu et
ce qu'ils auront lieu dans leur forme
actuelle
mais à partir d'aujourd'hui il nous
reste exactement quatre années pour
débattre de cette question et il est
probable qu'au fil des mois les réponses
modifieront en fonction des décisions
des événements sportifs ou
extra-sportifs
mais à l'issue de ces jeux de moscou en
1980 on peut envisager les choses avec
un certain optimisme car en dépit de
tous les problèmes qui se sont posés
l'olympisme une fois encore a survécu
oui il y a eu des absents et beaucoup
d'épreuves s'en sont ressentis oui une
quinzaine de pays ont refusé le rituel
classique
oui les délégations occidentales ont
continué de condamner les exactions
soviétique
la démarche française ayant été
d'ailleurs à cet égard la plus active
mais enfin qui peut dire aujourd'hui
qu'au plan sportif olympique et même
quotidien tout ne s'est pas bien passée
à moscou organisation remarquable
performance digne de celle du passé pas
d'incident notoire une sécurité efficace
et s'il n'y avait eu cette espèce de
liberté surveillée horripilante
qui pourrait dire aujourd'hui que tout a
été peint tout n'a pas été parfait en
tout cas les athlètes eux ont joué le
rôle qu'on leur demandait et grâce à eux
donc le mouvement olympique s'est
maintenue nul doute bien sûr que les
modifications amorcé à moscou vont
pendant les quatre ans qu'il nous reste
avant le sens devraient se multiplier
la notion de nationalité par exemple va
probablement complètement disparaître
désormais on ne comptera plus les
médailles par pays mais par champions
les cérémonies perdront de leur
amplitude
on sait par exemple que monsieur sarah
manche le nouveau président du comité
olympique international à l'intention
d'annuler les remises de médailles sur
le terrain pour qu'elles soient toutes
décerné quotidiennement le soir après
les épreuves au village olympique
quant au lieu des prochains jeux il
demeure pour l'heure los angelès mais la
solution olympie n'est pas encore
écartée en réalité dans la mesure où
nous avons la conviction que le
mouvement olympique est maintenu toutes
ces questions sont plutôt du domaine du
détail
une seule en fait est importante à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui quelle sera
l'attitude des soviétiques à l'égard des
jeux de 1984 le vice-président exécutif
du comité d'organisation des jeux de
1980 monsieur vladimir popov a toujours
répété qu'il était hors de question pour
les soviétiques de ne pas participer
recharger en revanche il se pourrait
qu'il boude certaines compétitions moins
importantes comme ils l'ont fait déjà
par le passé pour d'ailleurs des raisons
politiques
par ailleurs on sait que les soviétiques
n'ont guère envie de se rendre au
congrès du cio qui se tiendra en 1980 à
baden baden et en définitive leur
volonté de suivre la politique du cio
l'emportera probablement et il ne
devrait pas être absent des prochains
jeux olympiques
et même si cela était l'élite sportive
ne serait-elle pas aussi belle qu'elle
l'ont été cette année les exploits aussi
grand les performances aussi remarquable
quoi qu'il en soit le sport déjà
vainqueurs de la dernière olympiade
devrait enlever une fois encore la
médaille d'or de la prochaine avant de
voir la suite de l'actualité quelque
chose qui intéresse beaucoup de monde en
ce moment la météo et apparemment ça va
se gâter cet après midi il y aura encore
quelques orages sur les alpes et encore
s'il y aura des nuages et il pleuvra sur
les côtes de la manche ailleurs toujours
du soleil et de la chaleur
mais demain une zone de nuages va
traverser une grande partie de la france
il y aura demain quelques averses un peu
partout et après le passage de cette
zone
le temps sera beaucoup moins chaud que
ce week-end voyons maintenant l'ensemble
des autres informations de ce lundi avec
daniel lui le premier incendie de l'été
près de grasse n'est toujours pas
maîtrisée il s'est déclaré hier soir et
depuis ce matin cinq avions canadair
renforce le dispositif militaire qui
était mise en place une centaine
d'hectares a été pour l'instant détruit
mais le feu se serait aux dernières
nouvelles stabiliser les vacances du
mois d'août ont mal commencé pour une
dizaine de familles à cannes elles se
sont présentées en effet à la même heure
devant le même appartement qu'elle avait
loué avec enfants chiens et bagages la
faire c'est bien sûr régler au
commissariat et là on s'est aperçu que
la propriétaire de l'appartement madame
chan kern qui a 60 ans n'était pas à son
premier coup d'autres vacances perturbée
mais cette fois encore c'est pour
d'autres raisons
onze attentats ont été commis la nuit
dernière près d'ajaccio et de bastia
neuf d'entre eux visés des
transformateurs edf autre inquiétude le
cyclone allen menace l'île de la
martinique ainsi que sainte lucie ils
avancent à vitesse de 35 km heure avec
des vents soufflant à 140 km en social
toujours pas de solution dans le conflit
de pêche à boulogne-sur-mer
il oppose des armateurs aux pêcheurs les
premiers invoque les augmentations de
charges pour diminuer les équipages sur
les bateaux
quant au deuxième il refuse de faire les
frais de la crise et ils bloquent le
port résultat un seul chalutier parti
dimanche les 44 autres sont restés au
port avec leurs 900 marins brigitte
matin soutenu par les syndicats cgt cfdt
les marins pêcheurs s'opposent à la
réduction des équipages réduction
souhaitée par les armateurs depuis
plusieurs mois ces derniers invoquent
l'augmentation de leurs frais
d'exploitation due surtout aux prix du
pétrole
le ministre de tutelle joël le theule
seraient prêtes à apporter une aide
financière pour les carburants mais dans
la limite des règlements du marché
commun et la condition que les armateurs
réalise des économies de gestion
elle passerait notamment par la
diminution des effectifs embarquer
quatre hommes en moins sur les grosses
unités
deux hommes en moins sur les petites
vendredi le tribunal de boulogne sur mer
ordonnait le libre accès aux équipages
désirant gagner leur navire des
manifestants bloqués en effet la sortie
du port
après le désarmement de plusieurs
bateaux il y a dix jours malgré cela et
ça luthier étaient presque tous à quai
ce week end et ce matin la flottille
entière ne prenait pas la mer le conflit
persiste donc dans le premier port de
pêche français ou les syndicats a laissé
entendre qu'il pourrait bientôt empêcher
les importations de poisson transitant
par leurs ports remous chez les jésuites
le pape jean paul ii a demandé en effet
au supérieur général le révérend père
pedro à groupe ii sur choix à sa
démission il ya quelques mois le pape
avait critiqué les orientations
progressiste qui se font jour depuis
plusieurs années à la compagnie de jésus
iran une commission sera peut-être
prochainement créée pour préparer le
procès des otages amérique
le parlement iranien a en tout cas
décidé d'examiner cette proposition d'un
député
une chose est sûre l'ayatollah comédie
n'est pas du tout d'accord avec la
démarche du pape jean paul ii qui lui a
demandé que l'on respecte les chrétiens
en iran l'ayatollah commune il lui a
répondu qu'il devrait plutôt s'occuper
des jeunes iraniens qui selon lui sont
actuellement torturés dans les prisons
aux états unis à tel aviv ce matin un
attentat une voiture piégée a fait un
mort
il n'y aura pas d'élections anticipées
en israël les ministres israéliens sont
bien en effet d'accord pour dire qu'il
n'y avait aucune nécessité pour
l'instant du moins quant à la réponse de
monsieur begino président sadate
après le vote proclamant jérusalem
capitale éternelle d'israël
elle sera donnée demain le président
sadate a décidé je vous le rappelle d'
interrompre les négociations sur
l'autonomie palestinienne mais monsieur
begin a l'intention de lui rappeler que
le mois dernier le parlement égyptien
avait adopté une résolution proclamant
que jérusalem était arabe
julien galeotti notre correspondant
permanent à beyrouth a rencontré le
responsable de l'ump à propos de
l'annexion de jérusalem ne s'étant pas
très fasciste c'est un pas très
intransigeant c'est un pas illégal parce
que c'est contre l'opinion publique
mondiale ce conte la légalité
internationale et ce contre les
sentiments du peuple des palestiniens à
jérusalem contre les sentiments des
chrétiens et des musulmans dans tout le
monde nous croyons que ce temps pas
ridicule et c'est un pas qui montre la
mentalité de biguine et la mentalité du
clic sioniste en israël
est ce que vous avez peur d'une
confrontation à brève échéance
bien sûr nous sommes toujours pour la
paix nous ne sommes pas pour lui une
guerre et nous avons bien sûr peuvent
d'une nouvelle confrontation parce que
ce sera une guerre destructif essai sera
une guerre
peut-être nucléaire parce que ça peut
aussi engagé les contis ans dans une
telle guerre qu'on cela et nous croyons
que c'est à l'opinion publique mondiale
c'est tôt communautés européennes aux
pays de neuf de rester fermes contre les
israéliens et de montrer les italiens
qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire ce qu'ils
veulent dans la région parce que israël
vit sur néo z et sur l'appui de l'europe
et des états unis
on parle beaucoup en ce moment de
l'interféron c'est une substance
nouvelle mais naturelle qui pourrait
servir dans la lutte contre certains
cancers si on arrivait à la produire en
quantité suffisante ce qui n'est pas
encore le cas aujourd'hui
la production d'interféron est en effet
extrêmement difficile et surtout
coûteuse peu de laboratoires ci risque
pour le moment c'est un petit
laboratoire privé au sud de l'allemagne
qui en produit la plus grande quantité
et bien bernard volker s'y est rendu sur
place pour faire le point sur
l'interféron le laboratoire du docteur
anne claire et est spécialisée dans la
production d'aspirine lorsque son
propriétaire entendit parler en 1971 de
la découverte de l'interféron par un
savant britten l'interféron est une
substance produite par les cellules
humaines pour les protéger lorsqu'elles
sont attaqués par un virus friedrich von
schiller pense à utiliser à l'interféron
dans des médicaments contre le rhume et
se lança dans la production industrielle
mais peu après les savants américains
annoncé que l'interféron pouvait aider
aussi à la lutte contre le cancer
les souabes réagi rapidement et
décidèrent d'investir avec l'aide de
l'état 15 millions de marks soit 35
millions de francs dans la production
industrielle de l'interféron à l'origine
une cellules de la peau d'un bébé new
yorkais qui se divisent sans arrêt dans
le laboratoire
les cellules sont soumises à une fausse
agression virale et produisent de
l'interféron en quantité très minime
qu'il faudra ensuite purifié
l'interféron n'est pas encore en vente
il est essayée dans différents hôpitaux
les premiers résultats ont montré une
dîme
mission des tumeurs chez 21 malades sur
les 38 traités aux états unis en suède
70 % des malades atteints d'un cancer de
la moelle osseuse traités par
l'interféron vive
trois ans après le début de la maladie
avec le traitement normal ils ne
seraient plus que 20%
il est certain que l'interféron ne peut
être efficace que pour un nombre limité
de maladies virales ou cancéreuse si on
le donne à ses taux et à fortes doses on
verra plus tard s'il peut être associée
à la chimiothérapie
nous recevons beaucoup de lettres de
cancéreux qui veulent obtenir de
l'interféron en général ces patients est
aussi les parents des malades se montre
très compréhensif ils savent que ce
médicament est encore à l'essai et que
son efficacité n'est pas prêt à 100%
ils savent ce site que nous n'avons
qu'une quantité très limitée et il est
très difficile d'enlever à ces gens
leurs derniers espoirs
l'interféron éveil de grands espoirs
mais les essais doivent se poursuivre
encore longtemps avant que l'on
connaisse bien tous ses effets dans cinq
ans ce laboratoire de la prime pourra
produire assez d'interféron pour traiter
seulement 200 à 300 personnes par an
mais si les essais cliniques sont
couronnés de succès il ne fait aucun
doute que la production pourra être
augmentée en particulier par les géants
de la chimie qui n'ont pas encore fait
les efforts de la petite cuisine de la
prime
les opérations de pompage du pétrole du
tanio sont retardés on met actuellement
en place une colonne qui doit assurer la
liaison entre les navires de surface et
le fond où j l'épave retournée du
pétrolier ces opérations nécessitent
l'intervention de plongeurs qui
travaillent dans des conditions très
difficiles en raison notamment du
courant on a souvent parlé de cobaye à
propos de ses hommes
pourtant des recherches très sérieux
sont effectués sur les réactions de
l'organisme comme par exemple à toulon
au centre hyperbare de la marine
nationale qui vient d'être inauguré
notre envoyé spécial michel chevalet
c'est énorme cylindre d'acier est un
caisson dans lequel on reproduit la
pression veniant sous l'eau grande
profondeur
car à chaque fois que l'on descend de 10
m elle augmente d'une atmosphère
nous sommes donc au centre hyperbare du
jce mer de la marine nationale à toulon
une nouvelle installation qui n'a rien à
envier à celle des canadiens et des
américains
cet ensemble de caissons va servir à
l'entraînement des plongeurs de la
marine nationale et d'outils de
recherche pour étudier le comportement
de l'homme de très grandes profondeurs
entre 300 et 450 m
outre mendient à s'assurer que
l'organisme humain petit vive et surtout
il travaillait mais à toulon on a vu
encore plus loin puisque cet équipement
permettra d'atteindre la profondeur
fictive de 1000 m 1000 m cela représente
la pression colossale de sang atmosphère
on croit rêver ou plutôt ne cherche-t-on
pas le record pour le record enfin ne
pas vous parler de record c'est à dire
on fait des manifs de pointe qui permet
par la suite d'exploiter cette opération
de pointe et alors on travaille dans une
tranche inférieure pour permettre
ensuite d'arriver à cette profondeur
d'une façon opérationnelle
oui actuellement en cours de l'opération
janus 4 des plongeurs sont descendus à
650 mètres en caisson et en mer
l'opération a permis une sortie à 460
mètres avec l'exécution d'un travail sur
une tête de puits
seulement d'un exploit à la réalité
quotidienne
il y à un large fossé par exemple à
partir de 300 m apparaissent des
troubles nerveux à 450 mètres des
difficultés respiratoires
et si les 300 mètres mais bien à qui il
reste à bien maîtriser la tranche 300
450 m
est ce qu'il y ait de limites à l'heure
actuelle la limite de 653 difficile à
dépasser
compte tenu notamment mélange gazeux à
haute densité qu'on pourra peut-être
dépassé grâce à l'utilisation
d'hydrogène mais c'est encore d'un
domaine d'utilisation extrêmement
pélican est plongé actuellement en stage
sont étrangers de chaque chanson quand m
ce sont 200 heures se faire à mon ouïe
rien ne sert de plonger si on ne peut
effectuer un travail efficace sans
risque surtout on veut être sûr que les
transformations subies par l'organisme
ne sont pas irréversibles
se force à accomplir tous les gestes
avec beaucoup de maîtrise du poisson
avoir toujours en ressources une énergie
supplémentaire au cas où on soit sûr
pris part soit par un essoufflement soit
pas un effort non prévu à fournir et
c'est toujours cette ressource qu'il
faut pouvoir garder
est ce que je le sentiment d'avoir pris
des risques c'est pas une aventure ont
parfois sans être au courant du tout de
ce qu'il ya à faire est ce qu'il ya
derrière nous tout ce que représente
l'infrastructure qui est autour de ce
que l'enfant
après onze années de blocus la frontière
entre gibraltar et l'espagne sera
prochainement réouverte
les ministres des affaires étrangères de
grande-bretagne et d'espagne vont une
nouvelle fois se rencontrer pour fixer
la date
la situation avait été imposée par
franco en 69
mais le gouvernement espagnol a depuis
accepté de suspendre toutes les
restrictions imposées à gibraltar qui
est une colonie britannique depuis 1700
3 mai que les espagnols ont toujours
revendiqué
reportage hannache n'aidèrent
tous les jours à 18 heures se déroulent
au poste frontière la même cérémonie le
baisser du drapeau
hier personne n'y prêtait attention
aujourd'hui on observe en ce lieu une
certaine animation
les espagnols ont procédé récemment de
leur côté à quelques travaux qui laisse
prévoir une ouverture imminente de la
frontière
cet événement va sans aucun doute
bouleversé la vie des quelque trente
mille habitants de la colonie
britannique qui s'était habituée à ce
blocus instauré par franco en 1969
nous avons survécu
des restrictions ont été imposées dans
le cadre d'une politique visant à nous
étrangler mais on peut se rendre compte
que nous avons été capables de survivre
au blocus et que la vie maintenant et
plus prospère qu'elle l'était avant
quand la frontière étaient ouverts
pendant ses années de blocus
ils se sont détournés du mur de l'aïe
comme disent les anglais par dérision le
maroc leur a fourni de la main d'oeuvre
et des denrées alimentaires
londres leur a accordé des crédits en un
mot les affaires ont prospéré
peu à peu les habitants du rocher ont
pris conscience de leur identité génois
maltais hindous juifs venus du maroc se
sont sentis de plus en plus gibraltar
rien on en compte à peu près 20 milles
au près desquelles vivent 6000
britannique et quatre premiers
travailleurs étrangers marocain pour la
plupart des colonies se gère elle-même
elle dispose d'un gouvernement et d'un
parlement de 15 membres élus dont la
grande majorité favorables au maintien
du rattachement à la grande bretagne
cet anglais c'est drôle et c'est au
soleil dit la publicité
certes les peuples sont identiques à
ceux de l'angleterre
mais dans les conversations c'est la
langue espagnole qui est employée
parfois enrichi de quelques mots
d'anglais
les deux influences se mélangent tout
aussi dans les rues en revanche dans les
esprits et dans les coeurs
l'indistinction est très nette
georges darien sont répétés envers les
espagnols si c'était une question de
votre volonté de la part des espagnols
la frontière se seraient ouvertes au
cours des quatre années qui viennent de
s'écouler
car voici quatre ans que la démocratie
existe en espagne et rien ne s'est
produit
la population dans son ensemble n'est
pas hostile à l'ouverture de la
frontière elle en mesure les avantages
pour le commerce et le tourisme
mais en redoutent aussi les
inconvénients pour l'emploi et la
circulation des véhicules
en réalité chacun a conscience que
l'ouverture de la frontière est en
quelque sorte une condition à l'entrée
de l'espagne dans la communauté
européenne il reconnu en grande-bretagne
que le parlement serait il sans a
ratifié l'entrée de l'espagne dans la
communauté avec une frontière fermée
par ailleurs le destin de la colonie
britannique est liée à l'otan c'est en
effet une base militaire que la couronne
met à la disposition de ses alliés
aujourd'hui on peut s'interroger sur
l'importance réelle de ce rocher de cinq
kilomètres carrés six ans tandis que les
armes sont de plus en plus sophistiqués
et que se développe la stratégie des
missiles nucléaires mobile la question
de savoir si des missiles sont installés
dans le ventre du rocher est devenu sans
intérêt
l'appartenance de l'espagne à l'otan
autoriserait la présence de ces
militaires dans la base de gibraltar
je pense que l'espagne va petit à petit
imposé sa présence militaire à travers
l'otan l'influencent britannique va
diminuer progressivement au profit d'une
influence plus large des pays de l'otan
en particulier de celui présent sur les
lieux
c'est à dire l'espagne les espagnols
préféreront sans doute ce processus de
pénétration lente à tout règlement
politique trop rapide
car en face les marocains s'apprête à
soulever la question des deux enclaves
espagnoles sur leur territoire melilla
et ceuta dont on distingue les contours
dans la brume de leurs rochers les
célèbres singes de gibraltar vont donc
l'assisté très prochainement à
l'ouverture de la frontière et voir
déferler les espagnols la légende veut
que lorsqu ils disparaîtront les
britanniques s'en iront aujourd'hui les
soldats de sa majesté continue de les
nourrir
restez avec des méditerranéens
maintenant robert castel et danielle
st-amand à l'occasion de la sortie d'un
film sorti cette semaine mercredi
prochain un film dont je vous lis le
titre parce qu'il n'est pas dit pas
facile du tout mais qu'est ce que j'ai
fait au bon dieu pour avoir une femme
qui boit dans les cafés avec les hommes
ont expliqué c'est un titre qui est une
boutade c'est pas tout à fait c'est un
petit peu pour donner le temps mais
qu'est ce que j'ai fait au bon dieu pour
avoir demandé de leur dire mais qu'est
ce que j'ai fait au bon dieu pour avoir
une femme qui voit dans les cafés avec
les hommes
c'est un titre qui est un petit peu une
boutade qui donne un petit peu le ton du
film qui est qui et qui comme chacun le
présume n'a rien à voir avec richard iv
de shakespeare c'est rien à voir avec
hamlet encore que par mon personnage
elseneur et moi on se rapproche un petit
peu quand je vous disais en début de
l'antenne je suis venue des chevals
jannik hansen en suède et en norvège
oui d'ailleurs ça se joue ça s'entend
mais indépendamment des questions de
faux ni ça c'est pas ça c'est des
détails
ce qui est important c'est que c'est une
comédie etc avec un titre pareil ce que
je voulais dire c'est que le
le temps est un petit peu donné sur le
site comédie genre difficile s'il en est
robert castel on en reparle dans un
instant je vous propose tout de suite de
voir justement un extrait de ce film
pour voir que ça n'a rien à voir avec
hamlet absolument alors là vous qu'il
est amoureux de moi c'est ça qui te fait
rire je pleure ça fait rire oui ça me
fait mourir de rire
alors ce type
je savais qu'il était pourri jusqu'à la
moelle ça je pouvais toucher mais qu'il
était fou
alors ça je ne savais pas ça parce que
d'après toi il faut être fou pour le
vouloir faux comprimés ou vieillis mais
ce type il on veut pas de toi
il s'en fout de toi ce type là ce type
de ce type c'est me ridiculiser à moi
c'est humilier à moi c'est m'atteindre à
moi c'est probable c'est ça que tu dis
cabine personne ne peut me voir c'est
bien ça chez vous c'est bien mais aussi
entre mari et femme peut plus discuter
normalement bientôt un talent qu'il
remette à tourner sans pouvoir en parler
et bah bah elle mange pas avec nous
voilà donc un extrait de ce film mais
qu'est ce que j'ai fait au bon dieu pour
avoir une femme qui boit dans les cafés
avec les hommes
danielle st-amand vous avez signé le
scénario du film avec votre frère yann
qui a fait réaliser gala qui a réalisé
le film son premier long métrage en tant
que réalisateur et c'est ça le problème
c'est sa meilleure d'ailleurs eu un
petit peu c'est la dispute permanente
entre le rct mais vous avez vu ce que
vous avez vous avez une en mai fut payé
pour ça ce que vous avez vu c'est le
moment de la crise parce qu'il y en
quelques mots parce qu'on veut pas en
parler on peut parler jusqu'à 8 heures
c'est dommage parce que j'aurais
beaucoup de choses à dire
il s'est vraiment court ce journal ce
qu'on dise que c'est le moment de la
crise c'est quelques jours dans la vie
de ce type là qui est un dominateur
macho est ce que vous avez vu c'est
l'histoire c'est la crise qui va tout
déclencher qu'est ce qui va se passer
c'est ce que je demande aux gens d'aller
voir et y découvriront tout un univers
les qualificatifs moment que je préfère
vous les laissez pas ce que vous vous
êtes journaliste mais ce que je laissais
parlé un petit peu d'ailleurs cet amour
est ce que vous racontez quand même dans
ce film c'est le problème du
méditerranéen qui seront nos matches
c'est l'homme de 45 ans est conscient qu
il a toujours cru que sa femme était à
sa botte et d'un seul coup elle s'en va
elle le laisse seul et c'est sa réaction
il est complètement désarmé en fait
c'est son univers qui s'écroule et à
partir de là on a plein de ressorts
comiques est bon avec robert castel
évidemment le succès est assuré parce
que je crois que c'est un oui je tiens à
le dire si si on va découvrir un nouveau
robert castel je crois qu'il éclate dans
le dans le comique littéralement et à
mon avis il faut absolument aller voir
ce film vous avez écrit l'an dernier le
coup de sirocco un livre qui a été porté
au cinéma aussi mais là c'était on
parlait aussi d'aider des gens qui
revenait d'algérie qu'avec cet exode ont
parlé des pieds noirs je dire non non
affirme avoir parlé de pieds-noirs
méchant algérie sont aussi respectifs et
l'exode c'était le drame est aujourd'hui
à ses vingt ans après on sourit
aujourd'hui oui c'est à dire enfin on
peut pas en sourire il ya toujours des
problèmes mais enfin
ses vingt ans après donc on peut
commencer quand même à vivre normalement
rocher depuis longtemps la magie du film
comme thuriès le fait que dans les
rapports dans les situations vous allez
voir évoluer des gens qui sont
méditerranéen dans leur façon
d'appréhender les choses et dans dans
l'humour c'est un film c'est une crise
qui aurait pu se passer en bretagne à
fécamp ou un super coup c'est vrai ça
n'a rien à voir bon c'est un petit peu
spéciaux en sport pourquoi c'est
intéressant parce que c'est spécifique
qu'on me disait notre maître à tous plus
on est spécifique nous on est universel
c'est vrai des archétypes quand vous et
vous vous marrez la réserve mais c'est
vrai que plus spécifiques plus
spécifiques plus pourquoi le marius de
pagnol s'est traduit dans le monde
entier
il ya rien de plus mais dit et rien de
plus marseillais que la trilogie de
pagnol et s'est traduit dans le monde
entier
c'est pascal il aussi on peut aller le
voir oui allez wayne john kerr catamaran
partir de mercredi dans les salles je
vous rappelle le titre c'est important
de retenir notez-le si vous pouvez
m'aider et et apprenez le vous dirai
demain qu'est ce que j'ai fait au bon
dieu pour avoir une femme qui boit dans
les cafés avec l'exemple du lourd dit
encore une fois comme mais qu'est ce que
j'ai fait on retrouve rené tendront à la
bourse de paris jean pierre pernaut ce
qui fait qu'elle est elle aussi
universel malheureusement aujourd'hui
abords de paris on ne pourra pas vous
présenter les tableaux nous avons
quelques petits problèmes techniques
en fait il n'y a d'ailleurs pas grand
chose à retenir aujourd'hui sinon
d'abord la baisse du dollar le dollar
est revenu tout à l'heure à 4 francs
très ennemis il était monté à 4 francs
15 et vous vous souvenez sans doute que
la semaine passée ils avaient progressé
en quelques jours
autant que ce qu'il avait perdu disons
en trois ou quatre mois
alors on s'était interrogée sur cette
reprise de la monnaie américaine on
avait évoqué la remontée des légère du
loyer de l'argent aux états unis et la
diminution du déficit commercial aux
états unis en fait c'était un peu
exagéré mais probablement que cela a
suffi à influencer les vendeurs à
découvert de dollars et c'est la raison
pour laquelle c'est en racheter ils ont
favorisé une très forte hausse de la
monnaie américaine et le mouvement
semble pour le moment
terminer deuxième chose ici en france
comme dans le reste de l'europe malgré
la légère remontée du loyer de l'argent
aux etats unis c'est la détente sur les
taux d'intérêt en france et dans la
plupart des pays européens est
aujourd'hui sur le marché monétaire le
loyer de l'argent au jour le jour est
revenue
11 5 8e c'est à dire qu'il a encore
baissé d'un quart de point ce qui
devrait favoriser la détente des taux
d'intérêt dans les banques
cela dit ça ne favorise pas beaucoup la
bourse de paris aujourd'hui les valeurs
françaises sont assez irrégulière avec
des écarts très peu significative je
vais vous en donner quelques uns dans le
sens de la hausse nous avons moins
qu'ainsi en hausse de 6 francs à 563 la
lyonnaise des eaux à 371 francs gagne 6
francs également et je pense que vous
êtes intéressé par le cours de
l'aquitaine
alors un franc de hausse aujourd'hui sur
l'aquitaine qui avaient beaucoup baissé
la semaine dernière je vous le rappelle
dans le sens de la baisse trois
mouvements importants me semble-t-il
dick roussel uclaf et locindus enfin
dernière chose le marché de l'or le
marché de l'or une légère tension mais
très très léger c'est même pas une
tension sur le marché international 25
cents de mieux sur l'once d'or fin à
londres ce matin 622 $ 25 la barre à
paris par contre être un petit peu plus
soutenu 700 francs de hausse à 84 milles
le lingot gagne 205 francs à 80 3495 de
napoléon iv francs 10 à 745 10 et un
mouvement important
le quatre et demi pour cent indexé sur
le napoléon a gagné 35 francs à 2487
francs il est même en amélioration
derrière 2495 et 2493 le 7 % lui indexé
sur le lingot est en baisse profonde
7940 francs - 275 francs des arbitrages
vraisemblablement dues à des changements
de position après les indications selon
lesquelles le parti de monsieur donald
ray ronald reagan serait favorable à une
réinsertion de l'or dans le système
monétaire international ici la bourse de
paris avoue jean pierre pernaut merci
rené tendront une dernière fois répété
oui je voudrais répéter ce titre du film
qui sort le 6 août sur tous les écrans
parisiens nationaux qu'on va apprendre
d'ailleurs dans les écoles on va la
prendre à l'essai contre en compétition
dira copine et moi 50 fois qu'est ce que
j'ai fait au bon dieu pour avoir une
femme qui boit dans les cafés avec les
hommes voire voit un petit peu l'accent
vous laisse l'après midi ce soir à 20h
vous retrouverez dominique baudis pour
le prochain journal
au revoir et très bel après-midi à tous